[Applause]
Katy Perry gets booed on American Idol
wow I'm sorry I'm just saying exactly
what the viewers are thinking it all
went down during Monday's episode after
nutsa a 25 year old singer from Georgia
rocked out on stage performing Paris By
Grace Potter and the Nocturnals
[Music]
safe to say she did the thing while
competing in the show's top 26 in Hawaii
but Katie she had notes it's gonna bring
uh emotions out and that could come in
the form of anger one thing I personally
would like to see from you
it's not one piece of glitter the next
time I know that's going to be
gonna be hot
yeah the audience didn't like that and
they let Katie know Katie got booed okay
the first time in six seasons
but what I'm saying is that I'd like you
to flip the script I think we want to be
like pulled in by our hearts too exactly
I'd love to see that and I think America
might too and while the crowd may not
have agreed with Katie newtsa promised
to give a more meaningful performance in
the future we support them we nurture
them we give them constructive criticism
and they're really entering into a a
university and so we we just like teach
them everything we know in all of our
years of course this year the show is
mixing things up choosing to have a top
26 instead of the traditional 24. New
Talent is born every day and it's 26
because we literally could not pair down
right we added two more we were like
asking all the producers is this okay is
this like can we really do this I know
you guys have done this for 21 Seasons
but we we have really good talent we
can't send these people home so judges
Katie Lionel Richie and Luke Bryan
fought to keep more Idol hopefuls around
but during Monday's show host Ryan
Seacrest announced that one contestant
had bowed out of the competition so we
turned to the judge's first alternate
enter 16 year old Paige Anne
[Music]
make sure you wake up every day ready to
sing be ready to be be put in the moment
at any time be ready to sing so which
contestant left the show they didn't
announce or feature the artist but we
know it was 19 year old california-based
musician Beckett McDowell the son of
actor Malcolm McDowell and his wife
Kelly Kerr on Tuesday a Beckett
confirmed online speculation that he
competed on the show posting this snap
with his golden ticket explaining that
while he won't say why he decided to
bail on the competition he will say it
was his choice I am forever grateful to
my American Idol family and I will
always look back at the experience with
the utmost gratitude and fondness so we
won't see Beckett on the show but
something tells us the rest of this
season is going to be jam-packed with
Talent
la la la
[Music]